billions of people around the world
planning to ring in the New Year tonight
[Applause]
it is already 2019 in places like
Auckland New Zealand thousands of people
celebrated with a party and fireworks in
that western Pacific City here in New
York more than a million people are
expected to pack into Times Square
roughly seven thousand police officers
and heavily armed counterterrorism teams
will stand by to keep them safe and for
the first time this year a high-flying
security measure will watch from the sky
Tony Duke opal is in Time Square Tony
tell us all about it
oh good morning good morning this will
be the heart of the crowd in just about
12 hours that if you look over my
shoulder the ball drop is right there
let me give you an idea of the security
these barricades went up overnight all
the trash cans in this area have been
removed protectively and the NYPD has
even gone so far as to seal the manhole
covers under our feet in this area all
that plus an on-duty force tonight
described to me as larger than the
police force of most major cities any
night of the year
for the New York Police Department
preparing for New Year's Eve is a
year-long affair when midnight strikes
the ball drops and everybody goes home
we start planning for next year John
Miller is the NYPD's Deputy Commissioner
for intelligence and counterterrorism he
says people hoping to celebrate here
tonight will go through metal detectors
first no backpacks coolers or umbrellas
will be allowed some people may even be
patted down if officers feel there is
something they need to take a closer
look at it's not quite like going to the
airport because we've got to move it
through but it has some of the same
elements there will be plenty of police
presence
many wearing tactical gear and armed
with high-capacity weapons others will
blend in with the crowd on rooftops
snipers plus officers embedded inside
surrounding hotels so that if you have
something that occurs in a hotel either
before the event or during the event you
don't have to figure out well which
hotel is it how are we going to get
people there all of that built in like
last year more than 200 police cars and
sanitation trucks will block roadways to
prevent a car from driving into the
crowds but this year the NYPD will have
an additional set of eyes in the sky for
the first time an NYPD drone will be
part of the aerial arsenal
it's designed to supplement police
helicopters circling above and the more
than 1,200 fixed cameras in the ten
block area below how does a drone fit
into the overall plan the drone actually
is able to give us a view inside any of
the gaps between those cameras it gives
us flexibility visibility and agility
that you wouldn't have with another
device now important to point out that
police say there is no specific credible
threat to the celebration tonight but
according to Deputy Commissioner Miller
the NYPD has foiled roughly 30 terror
plots since 9/11 and their guard is
always up I asked him what he would say
to somebody who is worried nonetheless
and he said this is the safest place to
be in New York tonight and Anthony he
even brings his own kids they do an
amazing job Tony thank you